okay guys Disney we start today
celebrating Disney 100.
[Music]
look at that we get magic pants
good morning oh my gosh I haven't seen
you guys in such a long time I've been
caught up in Mom home life and I've been
too lazy to share it with you guys I'm
sorry but today and for the rest of this
week I'm gonna be sharing with you guys
the most amazing incredible opportunity
we've gotten so Disney invited us out to
spend an entire week with them for their
Disney creators celebration event they
invited a handful of people to come and
enjoy and just be pampered with Disney
stuff like I I just this is a dream come
true this is crazy like we found out
about this trip a couple months ago and
like especially Isaac and I have just
been ridiculously looking forward to
this week they invited us to celebrate
their most momentous anniversary 100
Years of Disney like that's why we're
here so check it out we even got a Magic
Band this is a hundred so it's four days
and three nights staying here at the
Disneyland Hotel and we're gonna be Park
hopping between Disneyland and
California Adventure and every day they
have these incredible events that is
just it's like once in a lifetime
pattern of experiences that I just I I
cannot stress enough when I say how
excited and happy and grateful I am that
we got invited to this so after
Disneyland hotel we're gonna be driving
down to San Diego and taking our very
first Disney Cruise we're gonna sail off
from San Diego go to Catalina Island go
down to Ensenada Mexico and then back to
San Diego and that's gonna be a four
night cruise I just am so excited to
spend a whole week
okay so we just checked in here at the
hotel and we got this incredible bag
that they gifted us and I'm gonna show
you guys all the goodies that we got and
also hello it's gonna be Luca's first
time at Disneyland so we did take a
Disney World trip over the summer when
he was like four months old or six
months I don't know how old he was but
he was still a baby now he's over a year
old he's walking by the way I haven't
even updated you guys with Luca at all
but he's walking he's signing things
like baby sign language and stuff you
guys will see but yeah so it's Lucas
first time at Disney and first cruise
ever there's just so many things to
update you guys with too there's just so
much so much excitement I just can't
even contain myself all right now let's
go check out this event
Isaac are you excited we're at Disney
all right let's check out what's in here
so Isaac and Casey got these hats I got
these beautiful platinum Mickey ears and
then
Luca which I don't know if it's gonna
fit him but he got these really cool
light up Nikki ears and then we got this
really cool OtterBox
some Ray-Bans let me see let me see let
me see I haven't even seen these yet oh
my goodness look at these they're so
cute hi Phoebe you excited hi look at it
with those little Air Force is so cute
like a Casey with Air Forces
Isaac with the Air Forces okay what else
do we have in here oh my God Disney and
Coach
oh glasses I love sunglasses oh my God
especially the ones without the nose
thingies these are so pretty Disney oh
my God is that teal oh my God they're my
favorite color
oh another oh my God more Ray-Bans oh my
goodness check this out oh I think these
are the ones I play music oh these are
the Ray-Bans that actually play music in
your ears oh
man you look so fly dude look at this
bag too I love it and we got Disney Food
and Wine Festival Sip and saber pass so
we get to try out all the yummies I've
been dying to go to this event like you
guys have no idea I'm so excited that we
get to try out all the food and when we
were at home before we came to this trip
they actually sent us a gift and I
posted on my stories and this Lounge
slide backpack was part of that gift
Disney has been spoiling us like crazy
I'm so grateful so thankful and now
Isaac's been dying for me to stop
vlogging so we could go check out the
parks because we have a four day park
hopper ticket that's loaded up on our
Magic Band which is so cool I always
wanted to try one of these so I'm just
so excited yeah look at him walking
hi
[Music]
come to Mama good job
good job these shoes still are kind of
too big for him so maybe they're making
him trip huh baby we're setting you up
for failure I got clown shoes on today
yeah you ready to go to Disneyland and
meet Mickey
[Music]
just in time for his nap I know he
literally just fell asleep right when we
entered the park because it's first
Disneyland experience
Isaac and Casey went off to the first
ride which is Splash Mountain and since
Luca decided to take his nap exactly
when we entered the park I and also I
didn't want to get wet so I'm staying
behind with Lupa as he sleeps he looks
so cute and peaceful with all this like
commotion going around it's so cute look
at him what a peaceful little boy not a
care in the world doesn't even know
where he is oh look who woke up good
morning my baby we're in Disneyland
oh you're a little cranky okay you're a
little cranky let's get you out there's
brother and daddy
Luca hey look who's back how was it this
one did you get wet yeah okay yeah
let me see turn around do a full 360. I
don't see any water on you at all oh
that's good you go ahead in the face in
the face yeah someone's happy walking
[Music]
what did you think Luca your first ride
all right so we're now leaving
Disneyland and we're heading to the
hotel to see if our room is finally
ready we finished off the day at
Disneyland by taking a picture right in
front of the castle because that's a
must but this entire day like this whole
day that I've been spending at
Disneyland it's been like this hits
different because I've never been at
Disneyland and then knowing that I'm not
going home at night like I'm actually
gonna be staying here at the hotel in
Disney like this is this is the first
for me and so all day today I'm like
it's just it's different like I'm just
so excited that we're not going home
we're actually gonna go to our room and
then after our room we're gonna go to
California Adventure there's gonna be a
car a private carnival at Pixar Pier
just for our group there's gonna be this
really cool exclusive party where it's
like a platinum party so I'm actually
wearing I'm wearing something sparkly
for the Platinum party so we're gonna go
enjoy that but first let's go to the
hotel and see our room I'm so excited
for
Disney hotel
all right
what do we think
all right so they just knocked on our
door
to deliver a present look at how
beautiful this bag is
let's see what's inside
oh we got a Disney 100
tumbler and look oh celebration popcorn
I am so obsessed with this like hologram
thing that they got going on for their
platinum and the 100 pin the Disney 100
pin that's so cute oh this is so awesome
being so spoiled but up next is the
Platinum party that they're throwing for
us as like a welcoming reception we got
a pack and play delivered for Luca opted
for this versus the crib because this is
smaller but there's one more thing that
I wanted to show you guys but first we
have to turn off all the lights
okay Isaac would you like to do the
honors please
oh my god well actually we need a little
leg cause you can't even see the castle
now look at that and it also has like
lullaby music you guys hear that
[Music]
it's a little button here that has like
a firework on it that is so cute I love
that we're totally sleeping with that
night light on it's so Disney I love it
okay sorry Luca I know you're trying to
go to sleep let's turn off all the
lights
can't take a snap we made it to the
Platinum Party
Casey stayed behind with Luca because
you tried putting him to sleep but then
he gave up so he's heading over anyway
look we're ready
look at my uh
this is like the most on theme that I
got but everyone here is dressed to the
nines I feel severely underdressed but
everything looks so cute
[Music]
look at how cute and Dapper they look oh
my God the cutest
were you fighting her on wearing this
yeah oh my goodness no you know I got it
look you look amazing no you could this
could be used for so many other purposes
Wes what are you talking about what else
could it be used
exactly you guys notice
what else constantly uh Bruno Mars there
we go there we go there we go there's so
many options you can Lounge on the
couches you know these things Easter
Christmas
every single holiday wow I could do this
all night I love it
[Music]
beautiful baby and Mickey oh my God
they're so adorable thank you for having
us at this beautiful party
okay so we just got on Guardians of the
Galaxy I have never oh thank you thank
you the professionals thank you so much
Wes for the light I love it okay Randy
so she said that every time she gets on
this ride there's like a million drops
I've only ever gone on this ride with
like a few drops we did it 39 times she
counted she was like we dropped 13 times
I'm like oh my God every time I think
I'm over it's not over Wes was trying to
take off his seatbelt and I was like
we're not done
we got the baby sleeping now these Casey
joined us now I don't know if I Vlog
that and we have reserved seating for
World of Color viewing oh my gosh what's
World of Color again is it the most
spectacular like water show okay
projection show the first time I saw a
World of Color back in like 2011 I saw I
haven't seen the newest World of Color
so I'm so excited that is next after we
get on uh the what is this called the
radiator springs Racers the cars right
the car's right that's what I call it
journey home
we're about to watch World of Color
yeah I love it
[Music]
thank you
[Applause]
okay oh my God I literally got period I
knew it I called it oh my God it was
just so beautiful where I'm like how do
they do this how do they come up with
this like how do they engineer this like
it's just so mind-blowing I was blown
away I loved it World of Color one
amazing and now for our entire group
so is everyone here everyone
we're all heading towards Spider-Man's
web Slinger by the way the park is
closed we're actually getting like an
escorted way to the westlinger's ride so
we're all gonna get to enjoy that ride
and after this is when we get to go back
to Pixar's ears and party it up carnival
style until like 12 45 in the morning or
something like that look at all this I
actually was incorrect when I showed you
guys the crowd earlier because that was
still part of people leaving the park
but everyone here because there was a
guy out there a bouncer he was like show
me your credentials and we're like we
got the passes dude we can pass so
everyone here now this is our group that
we're gonna spend an entire week with
and go to on a cruise Avengers music
hopefully it doesn't get us Content ID I
know remember when it like barely open
you waited here for like three hours yes
we literally were here when I was
pregnant I sat there for such a long
time waiting for this ride and now we
get to just freeze on through yeah it
was literally like seven months pregnant
the last time we came here
[Music]
[Applause]
for us to get into the pier
[Music]
[Applause]
are the rides open for us what's up
everything's open look at that all tours
[Music]
okay that was amazing we literally rode
the roller coaster Twice first we sat
all the way in the back and then the
second time we were all the way in the
front we're literally the only ones in
the tire roller coaster
can't get over it my hair is all messed
up now
foreign
[Music]
[Laughter]
he's here in stroller that's what it is
hey you guys got the whole family in
there that's really a family picture
[Music]
all right
oh my goodness all the games are free
for us to play and they're all open
[Music]
hahaha
so Luca is asleep and he's not awake
to do the portrait thing so we're just
full of the picture of Luca onto his
phone that's awesome
wow okay now we're literally like the
last ones here yeah like because we are
even finishing up our caricatures and
even everyone from our group is gone
because we're finishing these guys yeah
and we're literally getting kicked out
oh my God this was an incredible name
this is
this is all for Luca I feel that Mom
Gail is sitting in like crazy because
it's almost 1am and my poor baby has
gotten woken up so much he didn't get
his nighttime routine
oh he woke up
[Music]
say it again Casey was pitching to Isaac
he was like hey it's like fortnite
closing in us and Isaac was like uh
no it's because uh we actually was like
no no no
he's hilarious okay we missed it but
there was literally a line of crew
members or cast members just like
pushing us out like pushing us out of
the pictures like fortnite
nice
and apparently Casey made that joke it's
like a nice dinner responding so it
wasn't repeating it request laugh though
yeah I was with you it was like
Dad confirmed here Dad jokes there we go
dad jokes
[Music]
thank you